Okay, welcome to another Zoom Club.
A bunch of questions that came in.
And if you're new, most people chat,
there are other questions and so do you think
is something didn't have time to get something
in question in from the member site.
Let's go ahead and chat that question right in.
Remember, always go to the member site for information.
We'll state what's new, you'll see what's new.
We did have to raise our price.
This is the first price raise we've had.
I said 12 years, I think it's actually been longer than that.
Actually, 12 years ago, my price for cheek swab testing,
Kinesi Allen Chessi was higher than it is now.
So we did have to raise the price simply because
the cheek swab test take me 30 to 60 minutes each to complete.
And instead of charging 150 per 15 minutes
like we were doing, it's just $225 cross the board
and same thing with our calls.
So we had to do that with the increase of everything.
Please, please, please, while you said it a cheek swab,
please send in the online request form.
Or if you're not really good at online things,
print it out and fill it out and send it in.
But it'd be better for us if you did it online.
So you sent in your information online.
Also, if you personally added supplements
and you're taking other things, that's just fine again.
But I want to know what those are.
So if you can email me a list or send it a list,
PDF copy of a list would be best
or you could email me a list at info
or labs at huntersclinic.com.
That would be good.
Remember some brands like Ortho Molecular
that change your policy, they don't allow online sales
biotic research, doesn't allow online sales anymore.
Crazy, it's like they're in the stone ages
as far as how people buy things.
But it is what it is.
We can still carry them, we can still sell them,
we just can't have them visible on the store.
So if you need any of those things, call and just order.
We also now added a subscription thing to our website.
Had you get a 5% discount on anything
if you put it in a subscription.
Also, if you're going to do a call with me,
was it called educational coaching calls,
legally they're not a telemedicine call.
They have to state that a heavy site for that.
So you have to do the coaching call request form
and that you're basically cited.
This is not a telemedicine call.
We have to just stay legal and everything that we do.
Just be as skillful as possible to that.
Remember also that everybody has full access
to all the courses.
One of the questions that I have down here is,
do you have not that question.
Is there audio available for all of our courses
or our master classes?
Yes, so now that's just changed that just a couple of days ago.
You can download audio on any of our courses
on the video, sometimes you can do the audio.
I think there's a button somewhere on the course
that you can do underneath the information.
Also look at our blog.
There's almost a thousand blog posts
so you can search for anything you're looking for
if you're between Wednesdays or you want to find
some information on something.
Okay, first question.
I will be getting a PET scan for the first time today
and we'll follow it with high dose IV vitamin C
plus 1,200 milligrams of glutathione.
There's a later question about glutathione too.
A recommendation I recently received
to help remove the radiation.
I've had the recurring thought that I should also do a coffee
animal afterwards to support my liver
but I don't know what will help or will overwhelm my body.
Let's talk about this first.
The coffee animal is going to just support
your liver detox pathway.
So this is one of the best ways to detoxify
because remember a coffee animal is going to stimulate
your parasympathetics.
It's going to stimulate your immune system
and thereby stimulate your detoxification pathways.
So if some people can't tolerate coffee animals very well
but if you can tolerate a coffee animal,
it's the best way to help support your liver.
Also, something that I would say is if you have access
to a sauna, you want to help get rid of stuff
out of your body when you're exposed to radiation,
when you're exposed to dyes,
when you're exposed to chemicals,
when you're exposed to toxins.
And if you can do a sauna,
then you're just detoxing through your pores
instead of through your liver,
so you're taking burden off your liver.
Drinking a lot of water can be very helpful too.
So think of those kind of things.
Go back to my seven phases of detoxification course
using binders in the gut like charcoal
and sodium alginate and humate and humic acid
and things like that can be also very helpful.
Why would you use glutathione?
So I know there's been controversy about glutathione
and cancer.
We've talked about this last week or the week before too.
I used to be in the camp that I didn't want to use
glutathione with cancer.
I've changed my mind on that.
It's some different research that has come out.
Now I think glutathione is a positive per cancer.
What is glutathione?
It's your main intracellular detoxification antioxidant.
So what are oxidizing factors, oxidizing factors,
damage cells damage, DNA caused cancer,
damage cell membranes.
Their causes of cancer oxidizing agents,
reactive oxygen species are causes of cancer.
So, but the only caveat to that is chemotherapy
is an oxidizing agent.
Well, it's a poison.
We're basically trying to poison your cancer cells.
So if you were doing chemotherapy,
then you wouldn't do glutathione.
You wouldn't use alphalopeic acid.
You wouldn't use IV vitamin C while you're doing chemotherapy.
Well, why?
You need to protect yourselves.
Well, I know, but you are purposely trying to poison yourself
with chemotherapy, and it'll lead in a bad way.
You are purposely trying to poison your cancer cells
when you're using an oxidizing agent like chemotherapy.
So don't negate.
If you're choosing to do chemotherapy,
well, then don't negate its ability
by using a whole bunch of nutritional antioxidants
because they work and they will work
by decreasing the ability for chemotherapy
to kill cells or at least wait 48 hours.
So if you're doing IV vitamin C,
if you're doing glutathione,
you're doing alphalopeic acid.
If you're doing vitamin C, if you're doing higher dose
curcumin, things that are antioxidants that are so good
for you because they're antioxidants,
you can't do them for at least the first 48 hours
after receiving chemotherapy.
Well, this person doesn't have questionable chemotherapy at all.
They're talking about a PET scan and detoxify the radiation
and things.
Well, glutathione is good to help with any detoxification,
including radiation and such.
So it is good.
Now I know there's older information about glutathione
and well, glutathione can protect and help cancer cells.
Well, then everything you're doing to stimulate
your body healthy is doing that same thing too.
So I kind of don't agree with that philosophy.
So I do think that glutathione is beneficial for your cells.
I mean, there's no doubt about it.
And I do think that it has been a check to your healthy cells
and protect your immune cells.
So I think glutathione is a good thing to use.
I also have a bottle of cocoa tree at all on hand.
So what's cocoa tree at all?
So remember, the vitamin E molecule found in nature
has four outer shells.
Those are called tocoparols.
They're labeled alpha beta and gamma delta tocoparol.
Those are the four outer shells
who looked at other microscope.
Then there's four inner molecules of the vitamin E groupied
and those are called tocoparols.
The tocoparols are also alpha beta gamma delta tocoparol.
So it has been shown that the delta tocoparol is the most important
for protecting cells, for protecting your arteries,
for helping with brain, with your brain.
Delta tocoparol is essential.
That's why I like so many of our private label products
from designed for help.
Have a delta tocoparol base.
Delta tocoparol is also a fat.
So it's a great to use it as a base for supplements.
Instead of having to use what we were talking about last week,
the magnesium sterate or something like that,
that will help keep the product from binding.
So you're using a fat and you're using it
in a fat-soluble solution then.
So the delta tocoparol can be really good
to help pull out radiation.
Delta tocoparol can help protect your cells.
Delta tocoparol is the key component for arterial disease.
It can help relax your smooth muscles of your artery.
It's really a great component.
So how much do you take of that?
I don't know the product that you have,
but you literally can't take too much of it.
So that's the key component of vitamin E.
You hear what?
Vitamin E is good for your heart.
Well, only if you're using whole food vitamin E
that has all the tocoparol and the tocoparol
is really if you're just using the delta tocoparol,
that it's good for your heart.
If you're using the tocoparol so much of the cheap supplements
that you'd buy in the store,
you'd be vitamin E.
And then you look at it as alpha or mix tocoparol.
Well, that is just completely worthless.
It's good for your skin to open up the capsule,
spread it on your hands,
but it's not gonna be good for the rest of your body.
It's not how you'd get vitamin E in nature.
That's why cheap vitamins are cheap.
I'm curious to what you think of Ralph Moss's interview
regarding soy.
Do you still believe that soy is not beneficial
for breast cancer patients after hearing this?
He says the weaker estrogen of soy
lugs the whole in the breast cancer cell
so that the stronger bodily produced estrogen
cannot get into the breast cell.
Just curious if the genistine from soy,
that's an isol laboid of soy will help lower my AFP
or do you still advise me against it?
So I think what he was looking at with this
is hermented soy.
And he didn't state that in the interview.
And I think that was an error.
I do think that soy isol laboids are estrogen mimics
and they should be avoided for people with any breast cancer
even if you don't have ER positive,
or two positive, or PR positive,
even if you're triple negative,
I still think you should still use soy.
That'll give fermented soy is completely different.
Hermented soy actually removes the estrogen
from the estrogen beta receptor.
So it is the attachment of the bad estrogen
of the estrogen beta receptor
that blocks apoptosis.
It's not about estrogen getting into the cell at all.
So his statement about that is not correct physiology.
I think he's a great guy.
I interviewed him on my podcast before
and I don't think that's correct.
My tumor markers continue to go up
by oncologists isn't real concerned yet
about the tumor markers,
but it's concerned about the tumor coming to the surface.
The tumor seems to be getting more painful
around the tumor.
I also have an additional lymph node
that is popping up in the neck.
He wants to raise my eyebrows to 100 milligrams.
If I'm okay with this,
also he said that he is finding that letter is all
is not killing the cancer I can use to
and rather will be on both of the stront
which is a different drug.
So I do agree that sometimes you have to switch up drug
so I would be, you know,
I think that you have to refer to him about that.
I think that would be,
if I was in your situation,
I would probably do that.
Would I increase the eyebrows to 100 possibly?
The tumor marker is continuing to rise
by concern with that is the cancer decreasing.
Now he thinks, well, that could be
because the cancer is dying.
That's because you went back on the eyebrows
and that could be very well true,
remember?
That's why a lot of oncologists don't want to run
tumor markers if you're on a chemotherapy
because your tumor markers can actually go up
to begin with and that could get scary
but he's still making,
which I like to see this.
He's making a more clinical judgment
not just completely based on one test.
I do not want to go on the shot if I don't have to
because of the horrible hot flashes.
Now you've got to remember the horrible hot flashes
are actually an indication that it's working.
So we've talked about this multiple times
these zoom calls.
How do I get rid of the hot flashes
that I'm on an estrogen-reducing drug?
Well, the idea is that if you're on an estrogen-reducing drug
and it's working, you're going to have hot flashes
and if you take something like soy flavonoids like Jeniston,
you can help reduce the hot flashes
but you're, it's conflicting
because you are actually adding estrogen.
The whole idea is you're trying to get rid of estrogen
so you're, why do the drug in the first place then?
So that's why I disagree with this thing about Ralph Bosses
because you could take a person
with that's going through Metapause
and put them on a soy estrogen,
maybe of Jeniston and it will actually reduce their symptoms
because it's estrogen-like and it acts as estrogen.
Well, it will also act as estrogen
to the beta receptor, the estrogen-beta receptor
and cause issues with decreasing apoptosis.
What are your thoughts on this about upping eye brands
or about I'm all for it
and see how everything is looking before changing everything at once.
I'm all for that.
And if you think that you're not responding to the letters on
going to this, I would, I would refer to that.
Another question.
If I started the higher dose of eye brands in two weeks
to do the tumor markers that enough time to show change,
I don't know.
But in fact, I said, you know, you're on, you know,
the, if you're out of eye brands,
which, you know, the all the coercion
say it's out of chemotherapy, but truly it really is.
And actually your tumor markers can go up.
It doesn't always, but they can spike.
Again, that is really why so many standard oncologists
don't want to run tumor markers because they assume you're
going to do what they tell you to do, which is do chemo
and your two markers can go up and then they have to have a sit down
with the patient and try to talk about the cliff
because they're all freaked out because the tumor markers
went up and I did doing this chemo.
So I get it.
So, but if there's other signs that the cancer is growing,
that's why he wants to do the increased dosage and consider that.
What do you make of this success
trading solid tumors by injecting them with polio?
So here's a YouTube video.
I didn't get a chance to watch it.
But whenever you're adding something to the body
to stimulate immune response, that can help kill the cancer.
This is why we've seen people get a really bad flu
and actually put their cancer in remission.
The cancer went in remission after the flu
and it's not a coincidence because your immune system
was so hyper stimulated.
This is the whole thing about what's the guy's name
who used to inject toxins into people back in the 50s
and he was thrown into prison.
He'd have a mix of different toxins
and he'd injected it into people and their cancer would go away
because it was enough toxins to cause this immune response.
They get sick, they might have the flu,
they might be throwing up, they, you know,
but it's not enough toxins to kill them like the standard flu.
So if you're, you know, less you're 85 years old
and standard flu's not gonna kill you,
but it's enough to stimulate an immune response.
The whole idea of like bee sting therapy,
it's whole idea of mistletoe therapy, same thing.
Mistletoe is a human toxin.
So you're putting a toxin in the body
that's stimulating an immune response
and your body has to get rid of it.
It fires this huge cytokine response.
You fire this up tick in your immune system.
That's how mistletoe therapy works.
That's how bee sting therapy works.
Of course, it's just a little difficult,
made string because there's no muddy in it, sand,
but yeah, my oncologist is suggesting horrible blockers now
that I refuse chemo because I'm doing 20 rounds
of radiation for breast cancer.
I'm a testicized to several vertebrae in my spine.
I let breast as greatly deformed to the breast cancer,
but I don't think I want to take a horrible blocker.
Well, staying on the natural aerobatician inhibitors,
like we have you on, can be super helpful.
Are they going to be enough?
I don't know, but the bottom line is,
is a drug horrible blocker, you know,
does work as far as block eat hormones.
I mean, it shots everything down.
That's why people don't like them.
So it's, you know, if the bottom line is,
you got to trust your gut, you got to just pray about it
and see what God's leading you to do.
There's nothing wrong with trying, you know,
doing one thing at a time.
So if you're doing the 20 rounds of radiation,
then maybe you're going to say,
hey, no, I'm not going to do the horrible blocker right now.
I just don't feel comfortable about that.
What's the negative about taking the horrible blocker?
It's really the side effects.
That's the negative.
You just, you know, you will, you know,
you know, everything from every side effect
that you'll have from blocking your hormones.
Probably if most women would pipe in,
maybe the hot flashes are the worst.
I don't know, maybe with some women,
it's not the hot flashes, it's the vaginal dryness
or it's the headaches or it's not feeling heavy energy.
I don't know, but some people kind of cruise through it
and doesn't bother them as much.
But same thing with men when they go on
energy deprivation therapy.
Some guys tend to do okay with it.
Not many, most of them hate it.
So it's just you got to weigh through those side effects.
I'll be taking radiation treatments
and chemotherapy for seven weeks,
starting very soon.
What precautions would I take around other people
during that time?
You know, we touched on this a little bit last week.
What do you do?
The radiation is toxic.
I think you're given a recommendations
from the radiologists that you have to stay away
from people for ex-abounded days.
I don't, I never did radiation myself
and I don't remember what others have said
that recommendation is.
Depends on, I suppose, how much radiation
you're getting if it's just spot radiation
and something, probably there's no precautions.
But if it's a larger area,
you're gonna have a larger, what's called a rad dose.
And that leeches and it does,
it is a danger to other people.
Now, rad dose has a half life
and it will decrease over time.
Would outdoor meetings mitigate the rich?
Rich?
I don't know.
You know, anything, anything, any type of pollution
whether it's radiation or something else,
dilution is the solution.
So you'd think if you're outdoor
and it can dissipate in a greater space,
it would be better.
I would still follow the radiologists advice
that maybe double it or triple it.
If you say, oh, you're fine in two days,
maybe make it a week or so or more,
I would think of taking the glutathione,
the radiation drops,
any other detoxification,
like we mentioned, binders in the gut,
supporting your liver detox,
your coffee out of us, using sonas,
all those kinds of things that are gonna help
get that out of your body.
Is ghee safe to eat?
Yes, generally, yes.
Now remember, even if I have you on a dairy-free diet,
there's the question that we often get.
What about butter?
Well, butter is dairy, obviously,
but if you're just using butter very lightly,
and you're not using a lot of it on a daily basis,
butter is far better for you
than any of the plant-based, margarine type things.
So, you gotta kind of weigh that out.
What do you think?
It's not good, it's not old.
We already discussed that, I guess.
Zeolite is a binder, key later, slash key later.
And that's a great product too.
So, I love Zeolite and glutathione, so on.
I just started reading How to Starve Your Cancer
by Jane McClelland.
Are you familiar with this book?
What do you think of it?
So, this is using what has come to become
to notice caroncology approach,
which is using different medication
to help block the metabolic pathways of the cancer.
You can see Docs of Cyclean and Metformid
and things like that.
They can have benefits.
We have some people that may be on this call
that aren't doing some of those things.
The negative is that they're drugs
and they have side effects too.
So, you have to weigh that out
and feel what you're comfortable with.
The tumors of Medecare H, the positive in the last week,
were two I've developed two warts on my finger
on the same side of the next two words.
So, I think that's a different virus.
I don't think that's related.
Does this mean that the HP virus is still active
in my system?
Does that mean that
though the HP virus like most viruses
often stay latent in your body no matter what you do
so that you have
an empty bar, HPV, other viruses in your body
is, you know, fairly ubiquitous.
The warts are a different type of virus.
One thing about warts, if you guys know,
often warts are a side of zinc deficiency.
So, look and see if you're getting enough.
You're getting enough zinc in your body.
Zic is really important for cancer patients as well.
So, zinc and selenium are good for breast cancer
and prostate cancer.
Zic is good for all cancers.
I'm going to take you to your radiation.
I'll be your parents for two days
as I have PET scan CT scan schedule.
For tomorrow, do I need to take precautions
around people after these scans?
No, you don't.
It's not a radiation that's going to leach
really to other people.
I don't believe, and some people might argue with that.
Anybody can be hypersensitive to different radiation
and may have an issue with it.
But for the most part,
you don't need to be worried about that.
How long do you need to take the homeopaths
finish out the model of the homeopaths?
Audio available for the masterclasses.
Yup, I answered that.
It's on the masterclasses now.
I was reading a group that gluteethyl will be used
by cancer cells anytime.
Anytime we used.
Cancer cells are going to use.
I don't think gluteethyl is an uelsource.
Gluteethyl is an impact oxidant.
So, gluteethyl will be used by cancer cells.
If you're trying to poison them with an oxidized agent,
which is chemotherapy.
So, you shouldn't take gluteethyl.
If you're using chemotherapy.
Do you believe that spike proteins from the vaccine
shed to other people?
Absolutely.
I do.
If yes, how do we protect ourselves at our loved ones?
So, quite honestly, this is what this is the.
Okay, so let's take a step back in history.
How we started practicing and seeing cancer patients will go to far back.
Let's just go back five years.
Five years ago.
We always had a distance program, which almost everybody on this call.
Started on our distance programs.
Um.
Looking at anybody.
Maybe one or two of you came to our office.
Um, and you started on our in office program and then everything was distance.
We had two days in the office.
So, the option was you could come and spend two days in the office where we do.
If you started on a kickstart with detox, we have a bunch of equipment that we used.
We did thermography.
We did a bunch of stuff.
We did an in office testing that you would hold with your right, but you started that way.
Um, but a lot of people even at that time did the distance plan.
We probably had about 70% of the people did the in office and 30% of the people did distance.
And we had found over years of doing that that really.
We had just as good a success with distance as we had with people coming to the office.
But there was benefits of people coming to the office.
We always thought because we developed a closer relationship with them.
We got to see them for like eight hours for two days and it's damn right out of the hotel and it was.
It was great experience because we love to develop those relationships.
Then COVID hit right and basically shut down tons of clinics.
We just refused to shut down.
And I refused to wear a mask.
So I just, I'm just we're not going to play that game and, you know, I already knew the studies on masks.
But, you know, decrease the transmission of a virus. They're not going to.
They're just going to make it sick. Hopefully that if you guys are wearing a mask, we've had this discussion.
You know, 50 times on the zoom calls back when COVID was, was active.
But they just are a harbor space for, for bacteria and a chance increase chance of you developing.
There's no pneumonia and other issues that certainly a cancer patient doesn't need to deal with because it's.
What are the top causes of death by cancer is pneumonia.
So for cancer patients. So we don't want people wearing masks.
We didn't want people to have to travel.
But by their own.
Desires because of issues in everybody's state with the practice literally flip flopped overnight.
30% of the people were coming in actually less than that.
percent of the people were coming in actually less than that, maybe 10 to 20 percent of the people were coming in to do the two days in the office and in the rest of the people were choosing the distance program.
Well, then once the vaccine came out, we had patients and some of you might be on this call that got the vaccine.
No, I'm totally 100 percent against the vaccine.
And but I'm not going to go into a huge discussion about that. Everybody had to make their own choice about that.
But shedding from the vaccine was making me sick. So understand I have my own cancer.
And I would just get sick after somebody came in that was vaccinated. Sometimes it wasn't the patient. It was the spouse of the patient or he had he or she had to get vaccinated for their job or whatever reason is their reason, but I would get sick and it's like, there's just no what is going on with this.
I contribute to the to the shedding and it was an issue for me and I just said that's it. We're done. I'm not going to die from, you know, the shedding of the vaccine because we are stuck in a model that we don't need to be stuck in we had just we have just as good a success with people doing the distance plan.
And we're sad about it because we don't get to develop that same relationship with people, but we're still I'm still alive. So I guess about two sand about it. So it's that's how we switched to that now we recommended we came up with a product with this whole thing came through that was that's called clear CV. So clear CV was a product for
the coronavirus. So that was for the coronavirus. And then we recommended for shedding. We always recommended lumbro lumbro kinase, dado kinase and some other binders.
Well then now just just recently we have a new private label product that's specifically formulated to help with spike proteins and it's called clear talks.
So clear talks has lumbro kinase. So instead of having to buy the U.S. enzyme lumbro kinase and the dado, instead of buying four supplements, it's all in one supplement called clear talks.
So that's got the binders. It's got the enzymes, the lumbro kinase and the dado kinase that's specifically meant to pull the spike proteins as best as we know how to do so at the current time.
And that's a good thing to take. Now I still personally avoid to, you know, any close contact with people that I know are vaccinated. I do know that the spike proteins wait over time. So if it's been time that they I am not gotten sick from any spike proteins. I don't think for a long time.
I do think that most people are not continuing to get vaccinated. They did it once or twice and then because they had to and then they're away from that. I did share a story last week because Fred the bite is a medical doctor and he just got a job at at mail and in December and they forced him to get the vaccine or they wouldn't allow him to start.
And he said his life just took a giant doctor. He said 100% different difference. Well, he just started. He just bought one of our home.
PMF devices. He's got a right at home. And he's using the PMF device and he said he really, really helps him and made a world of difference for him.
Did the HP lower on my right. I did the HP lower program on my right three or four days ago. The last two days I had two three inch looking worms one on Tuesday and one Wednesday that came out in my stool. So I understand that's not HP lower.
So the frequencies for HP lower I may have killed the worms if they are worms and that's not so I'm not doubting that but HP lower I is not a worm.
So I looked it up and it appears to be a rope worm. Okay, I should finish reading this. I guess I was very nostalgic. Both of these days not feeling good.
Just wanted to sleep. Excuse me. No energy. Today I feel good again.
Could it be from the HP lower treatment. Yes, it could remember these are frequencies. So just because of frequency. It's been shown to help with HP lower it doesn't mean that it won't help with other parasites.
So that's very good news. I wouldn't do it again. I give yourself some time to recover and do it again.
How do you treat candida? So any type of yeast infections has to do with an imbalance of your microbiota.
Now there's we have different nutrients that people take it really depends on how chronic this yeast infection is how stubborn this yeast infection is.
Definitely running some of the candida programs on the right is important.
And then if you don't want to start taking another supplements. So I said my candida program that was very effective and it's trying to get good probiotics into every orifice of your body.
One of the ways that you could increase the efficacy of a probiotic supplement is to put it in a culture. So let's take so yogurt. So let's say you just bought some yogurt. There's enough to be dairy yogurt.
Try to stay away from dairy so you can use coconut yogurt. Just get it just get a plate coconut yogurt. If you can find it or an almond milk yogurt or something like that.
That's your culture starter base. Then you could take a capsule of some different probiotics and it's good to mix up your probiotics and then put a capsule of that in the yogurt mix it up.
Or mix it up, set it on the counter, let it warm so that so that so the culture can grow the probiotic in there. It will typically liquefy the yogurt. It'll make it much more ready that if you have like an old saline, animal thing, you can squirt it up in there if you have some sort of way to
like a little what do you call like a little plunger thing that you can draw a draw up a syringe that you can draw up that liquid and then you want to put that in your orifices where you put that in your animal.
You would put it up your vaginal tract for a female and you could you do this in the shower. You'll want to take some of that and swishing in your mouth and let it kind of dry in your mouth a little bit. It won't dry but you let it coach your mouth.
You want to get that probiotic. If you're just swallowing a probiotic to help with with a Candida infection. A lot of it is dying with the with the with your stomach acid and it and your what is surviving is just going to your testicle track anyhow. You have to get it all your orifices even putting it on your hands and letting it dry out your hands and then rinse off and do this on a regular basis.
Those are some of the techniques that you could use for Candida.
I'm having more discomfort pain from the tumors. Can you recommend something to help naturally.
Any of the anti and laboratory things. So the anti and laboratory things are the flavonoids, the curcumin, the Boswellia, the betelene from from a
beats which the only product that has the pure betelene for the beats is the aloevia product.
And then the white willow bark.
So things that are in our clear inflamed product. So the anti and laboratory things are what you want to do. Those are the things that will naturally decrease the pain.
And then you can think of artica. You can get artica as an herb or you can get artica as a whole meal path. Those are things that some people really respond really well to artica. Also think of CBD CBD can be helpful.
And if it's legal in your state THC THC gummies can be super helpful. I can really help you sleep.
I can't get to that. It can make you a little bit loopy and some people don't like that but take it before bed. It can give you a good night sleep. That could be one of your best bets.
I was told the limit eggs. What if I bought eggs that are corn free, soy free is that different? No. So there's no difference in that. It's still going to be still going to have that egg protein in it.
And then your markers have slightly come down. The tumors in my left breast are smaller, but the tumors my right breast seem larger. The right breast has a tumor wild and had a biopsy. What are your thoughts, the tumor wound. Sorry, it had a biopsy. What are your thoughts?
Well, I don't know the the tumor, the right breast might be more inflamed right now. So that might not be a bad thing that it seems larger. It might be because your immune system really needs to address that and kill that. And it's really because of the inflammation.
Cause for the immune response. I don't know that for certain, but I would go with that thought. And if it is, if you had a biopsy there, you have a tumor wound. Well, then you're going to have scar tissue that's never going to go away. And it doesn't need to go away either. So I wouldn't necessarily worry about that.
Because scar tissue is just my body and it's not cancerous. Is it safe to try taking mistletoe tincture? Yes, it is.
But I don't think it's as effective at all, even close to even the same book as a mistletoe injection or IV.
But I was going to remain a pause and started having hot flashes. I started taking a homeopathic remedy that made my hot flashes go away completely. Could this have thrown my hormones out of natural process and cause a bakery and exist.
If you would have said could this have thrown my hormones out of the natural process and caused by.
The ER positive breast cancer, I would have said, yeah, maybe.
Well, biopathic is powerful. But to cause a bakery and exist, yeah, I don't think so. Yeah, because I don't think that is estrogen receptor positive.
I don't think that has, I think I don't think that has anything to do with the hormone would have anything to do with the hormone about so I would say no on that, but that's just my guess.
How much zinc should I be taking? So, and how do you like to receive test results from other practitioners? So test results can just be sent to labs at countersclinic.com or info at countersclinic.com where they'll go in your file.
If you want to talk about them, then you just call them in an appointment.
How much zinc should I be taking? As a general rule, 50 milligrams of zinc every day is what you want. Now, on all of you guys, so this so you know, because maybe some of the new people don't know this.
When you said, like, oh, I'm taking this supplement. Some of the reasons why I said stop taking this supplement. It's not one of ours, because ours don't have this in there.
At least nothing that I would recommend is because it has copper in it. So copper and zinc are like antagonists in your body. You need both. Don't get me wrong. But you have this copper zinc balance.
Copper stimulates growth, zinc doesn't have any growth, but they're, they're a mineral complex in balance.
Most people with cancer have it accessible to copper to zinc. So their copper zinc ratio is off.
It's probably off, but it's off. And there's been a lot of assessment and some studies on this. Your copper zinc, zinc to copper ratio.
And that's why I don't think a cancer person patient should be taking an exogenous copper. You'll get copper at your food plenty enough for your body to stay alive and not have a copper deficiency.
It's, we can get too much copper, you know, people have copper canals. They have copper pipes in their house. They have copper sources. And, you know, people, this whole bad about wearing copper jewelry for this or not or something like that.
Access copper. That's all bad for you copper on top of that. It's all elemental copper, which is even worse is throws off our zinc balance and that can lead to at least a piece of the cancer puzzle.
So that's why I've taken everybody off copper.
And just going off copper is usually brings the zinc balance back into place. But should people take more zinc? Well, anybody's taking any of our minerals, you are taking more zinc and our minerals don't have copper.
So, but how much copper, how much zinc should you take? It depends on what you're trying to do. Let's say if you have something call me and say, hey, I have warts. I just want to get rid of my warts. I'd say take 50 milligrams of zinc a day for a week and then off a week and on a week and off a week and cut is good to cycle that like that for warts.
You know, typically 15 milligrams of zinc is fine, but 50 milligrams of zinc is taking just more zinc. You can't really overdose on anything else, but you're not going to really overdose on zinc.
I'm scheduled for a CT and MRI back to a back June 15.
Both will be with contrast so far. I have tolerated contrast with no issues, but concerned that impact to liver. I do plan to do homeopathic treatment for MRI thoughts on doing this back to back.
We've had a lot of people do it back to back with no issues. I would just do everything we talked about earlier about doing everything to support your liver, you know, if you get delivered, clean down as much as possible, you'll be able to cruise through that and flush that garbage out.
I will do an MRI at the end of the month. Can I start using the homeopathic droppers now? Yeah, I mean, you could take homeopathic radiation droppers.
No sense. Well, take that back. There's really no sense of taking the the catalytic of droppers.
If this was you're doing a CT scan at the end of the month that you want to take the radiation droppers, we're all exposed to radiation at a daily basis. So yeah, it would be good to take the radiation.
Holyopath, but you're not exposed to get a lidium on the regular basis. So I would wait until you know a couple days before your MRI to start taking it.
I lost a healthy amount of weight after we started our program, but my stomach is still a bit bloated at times. I do a coffee at a bit every day.
Nobody who has ever muscle tested me has told me I need digestive enzymes, any ideas.
Well, I don't want to overlook any areas of detoxification. Well, I think that I don't think anybody could be hurt by taking digestive enzymes with your body's making digestive enzymes.
So I would, if you feel bloated, you should be taking digestive enzymes. I'll tell you they don't always come up on muscle testing. There's a certain physiology test for HCl.
There's not a specific physiology test for digestive enzymes, so I would go ahead and take them.
It was number one thing in good hearts book was HCl and digestive enzymes. That was the number one thing he thought everybody should be on them.
Did you know Dr. Patar, I met him once and talked to him on the phone another time he was going to be on my podcast.
It just never happened because it was right before COVID hit.
And then he got in the whole sorts of things during COVID because he was very outspoken and they just battered him.
So we'd never ended up getting a podcast schedule. Should I run a general parasite in rife or just do the HP lower again? Well, the HP lower after this did work. So I would do that again.
Do you have any suggestions for right programs for detoxing after the pet skin? No, I would just do your foot bath programs.
Is it best to go through menopause without taking any take it all? Just let it do its course.
No, so when you go through menopause, you're overly shut down and you know, gradually you produce less and less progesterone and estrogen.
Now women that go through menopause ago, I didn't really have any menopause symptoms. You know, I was glad I didn't have my period anymore blah, blah, blah.
I know I kind of sailed through it. They have really healthy adrenal glands. So your adrenal glands do make some estrogen and progesterone.
And they're supposed to kind of make up the difference not at all the same amount, but they will make up the difference so you kind of go through menopause in a nice gradual way as you're over restart to degenerate.
People that have serious problems with menopause, we're not talking about people on estrogen, lowering medication, we're talking about just menopause.
Our ovaries are shutting down and they have serious hot flashes and symptoms. You really want to support the adrenal glands.
So especially if you have a history of breast cancer, you don't want to go and give soy bison flavonoids like we talked about with jettison or something like that.
If you have a history of breast cancer, if you don't have any history of cancer, that's what I would use. But if you do have a history of cancer, I would only use adaptogens.
So you do things that will support a adrenal function, but you might not need to. So let's say, you know, you particularly had a lot of supplements that say you need to do that.
But supporting a adrenal function is what you would do if you had symptoms.
Is clear talks of good remedy for people who have had the vaccine? Yes. So it's for people who have had the vaccine, add for people who are exposed to people who have had the vaccine.
Is clear talks good for mold? No. Not really. No. No.
That's a whole other discussion that it's for. It's it's it's not for clear on Michael toxins.
Is it good to ask for MRIs and CTs without contrast?
No, because yeah, you can, but you can't see the same things.
So I was told that the heavy metal in the Galilean stays in the brain.
And it can build up where people really have problems. People, people have sensitivity to it. They can have a reaction. You get really sick, but if you've had it before, you don't have that the chance of that happening is pretty small.
It's a very small percent of the population that have that type of reaction. So again, again, you go back to my bottom line of this is you only do these invasive tests.
If it's going to change the way you treat. So you don't do an invasive test like MRI with gadolinium or CT scan, which is just by itself, without contrast, there's a lot of radiation.
You don't do that if you're just trying to satisfy curiosity. So you only do it if it's going to change the way you're going to treat it.
And of course, for the medical doctor standpoint, they're like, yes, it's going to change the way you treat it because if this is positive and we see changes that we're going to up this dose or change this dose, I get it.
But if the patient's like, well, I can let you do that anyhow, well, then don't do it. So you're the ultimately the person has to deal with all these things. They will go home, you know, to their families to the end of the day, you got to deal with the garbage. It happens afterwards.
So you have to, you have to weigh those things out. Okay, well, I'm not going to do any more of that. Anyhow, I'm not going to get that MRI or CT scan.
Because even the CT scan without contrast is sometimes a radiation, it's like 50 chest x-rays.
But if you can't do the toxins, then if you can't do the deal with the toxins and know that catalytic is builds up on your system that can't that is an issue. So that way those things up can kids take cleared talks. Yeah, kids could take pretty much any supplement, but you just dose it via body weight.
So you'd, if it's a small child, and you just got it, okay, clear, clear talks, you know, typically if you're an adult, 150 to 250 pounds, you might take 2 to 4 to 6 a day, depending on if you had to get vaccinated or you're exposed on a daily basis to people that are vaccinated or you're exposed to somebody freshly vaccinated, you're going to take more.
You'll take less if the person was vaccinated that I work with this person and they were vaccinated a year ago, but haven't been since you're probably out a whole lot of danger that sloppy anything from them at this time.
But you just dose it, you know, you know, just think of their body weight and how you would dose it up.
So US enzymes is a good is good to start is their HCl in that are you talking about the enzymes.
So the HClzyme is is if you have that the HClzyme that's how it's spelled like that is the US enzymes HCl plus digestive enzymes.
Our private label clear, what is it called digest or digest, I think it's called is designs for health digest items.
And I actually like that one better because it's got a better mix of enzymes and actually I think they source the enzymes from US enzymes.
So they're the same thing, but I think it's a nice, a better blend for somebody just for digestive purposes.
So it's just like, oh, just for my stomach to help me digest, I'm getting bloated, I would do the clear digest plus is a better value.
You get more a lot more in the bottle and it's a little bit less price.
Gold is also good for me with that one, but I would, if you have especially a bloating, I would get one with HCl in it.
And remember, if you get a digest or enzyme with HCl and if you only take it, when you eat, so you don't take it on an empty stomach.
So you're only taking it when you eat, so like my wife carries some interpersonal little baggy.
So if we eat out, we take one, when we eat, and you'll get, you get to a point where you know, I need to take a couple when I eat this type of food.
So when I eat meat, I have to take a couple, three of them, or I'm going to eat, you know, something else that I don't have to take anything, you'll cut it, get to know that.
And how you dose it is, you kind of, I trade up as well, what a help to a little bit now next, I'm going to take two, I have to a little bit more than three.
Oh, that really helped. You still don't have to take three every time you eat.
You might have to do that for a week and then tie trade back down to two down to one again.
You're really trying to take pressure, when taking digestive ends, I would say, you're trying to take your taking pressure off your stomach's production of each sale.
And you're taking pressure off your pancreas production of digestive enzymes.
Yesterday at the oncologist, my temperature was 100.4, I just took it and get it, it's 100.4.
You asked you to get a CBC, so you probably did that, when you get the results, if you could send that to me.
Of course, when you have a elevated temperature, you want to, you think that there could be infection, right.
And so having night sweats, but not daytime hot flashes.
Yeah, well, night sweats are tied to cancer itself.
Flashes are tied to a sudden, strong fluctuation, down fluctuation, estrogen.
And the night sweats that are tied to cancer, they don't really know why it happens for some people and it doesn't for other people.
They think it's a fluctuation in hormones.
There's a lot of theories on why the really interested to see what a CBC looks like for you because we want to look at that white blood cell comp.
Everybody thanks for being on tonight.
Know that I'm praying for you guys, I love you guys, and just keep up the good fight.
If you need to call, make an appointment to talk to me personally, you certainly can, but know that whether we ever see each other personally, hopefully we'll see each other all in eternity.
That's my ultimate desire for you guys, and my ultimate prayer for everybody.
Know I'll be praying for you, love you all, bye bye.